welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is going to lakritz er an associate
professor in the Department of Music at
Yale University in both her writing and
her teaching professor Kreutzer
approaches music from a wide range of
interdisciplinary perspectives such as
social cultural and political history as
well as theories of multimedia today we
will talk with the professor Kreutzer
about her new book Verdi and the Germans
from unification to the Third Reich
welcome professor Kreutzer thank you so
much for inviting me let's begin with an
overview of your book and its premise
tell us about it
there's actually several premises with
which I worked one of them is very well
known which is that music was very
important for German national identity
especially in the 19th century when
Germany was not yet unified as a
political country there was a lot of
emphasis on music and Germany as a
country in which music is great Haydn
Mozart Beethoven etc sure and that
includes German language countries which
then included Austria the
austro-hungarian Empire so much larger
than what we consider Germany today
mm-hmm so that is a premise that is well
known and people have written about it
over the last decade but my question was
why should it just be German music that
is interesting in that context so we
know that collective identities and self
identity formations are often based on a
negative oil and negative either against
which you position yourself and so in
the political arena again that's well
known for Germany that was France the
archenemy and you have all these cliches
about French civilization versus German
culture and French fashion versus German
depth and all these things and so I
thought well in music it kind of been
just German music there must have been
another as well and so my premise is
that that was Italian music because
Italy had been a leading country of
music for many many centuries
and even in the 19th century when
Germans claimed to be leading in
instrumental music in particular
Italian opera was still very very
prominent in Opera is a genre that was
invented in Italy and by Italians around
1600 and that was still telling a pro
composers were still the most prominent
and popular ones and so in particular
and that's where my premise kind of gets
more narrowed and this function of
Italian opera is the other of German
music and German national identity
crystallized around the single figure of
Giuseppe Verdi okay and so where he was
born in 1813 and died in 1901 so his
career really spans the crucial part of
German nation formation in the
nineteenth century
and he was the single most popular
composer foreign composer in Germany
since the mid 19th century and so I
thought if we look at that nobody talks
about this nobody has talked about it in
recent scholarship none of the major
writings that we know of 19th century
German music historiography talks about
Italian opera but there must be
something he must have been talked about
he must have been at least Aksum to
German intellectuals and so if we look a
little bit deeper and look at what's
going on in the ground there must be a
shadow side of this ideology of German
nationalism and music so that's really
why I started okay and how did you come
to write the book what gave you the idea
well the idea was I've always been
interested in music in a larger context
and a larger historical and political
context and so also I've been interested
in ideologies and how they have
persisted and so the idea of German
music being leading was one of those
ideas that struck me as simplistic and I
thought I really want to go beyond that
and won't want to go behind that and
with that idea that German music was
really leading in the 19th century also
has been associated the idea that if
that's the case then German music must
also have been broadly popular Germans
must have been listening to their head
and one side Beethoven and then
Magne etc and what's that the case no
that was not the case so there's a whole
sub story so a very simple example is
the Third Reich everybody is very well
known that Hitler liked to Bogner even
fashioned his mine come funny inviting
as my name and so then the common
assumption is that Vagner was also
popular and Wagner was much performed in
the Third Reich but that's not the case
Verdi was actually more popular than
Wagner and was more often performed okay
let me ask you this how how do you know
that how did you do your research to
find that out for instance yeah I did
have I did a whole range of different
things which i think is also one of my
interests again in bringing music into
wider historical and political spheres
and vice-versa in for musical
scholarship by wider political
perspectives
so most basically I looked at a lot of
writing on Verdi in musical scholarship
of the time biographies of Verdi and
reviews of performances and then I
expanded from there I looked at daily
papers not just music journals but daily
papers of a wide political range wide
political spectrum then I looked at
statistics performance statistics in
various cities as well as overall to
just literally get an idea of how much
is very performed in other composers
which operas okay how do you find out
what performances were given back then
well there are there are statistics in
Berlin there's an archive that has
statistics from the very late nineteenth
century onwards and before that I
actually did a lot of reconstruction
looking at the major opera houses in
Germany at that time and when they are
putting on premieres so there was a lot
of detailed work done before I gathered
a list of important premieres in
important cities in fact for the 20th
century I have all German opera houses
and then I went from there and I looked
at reviews at important premieres and
revivals and new stagings etc and then
once you have the date you can go from
there but I also looked at iconography
images of Verdi and what
reflect about what's being thought about
very which is really interesting that is
one of my surprising findings and what
was it that literally the physiognomies
of Verdi and the way he's presented in
newspapers in portraits changes
according to what German things things
about him at the time so in the mid
nineteenth century he's still thought to
be the threatening other the
prototypical Italian the rough guy with
these very grim operatic subjects and so
he's portrayed as very dark and grim and
fears with you know furrowed brows and
all this and then later in the 19th
century the idea comes up that well very
so popular there must be a reason and
the German idea is that very was
influenced by vogner and by German music
and so his face changes in
representations and his nose becomes
shorter his face becomes fuller and
lighter and his eyes bigger and less of
a furrowed brow and then in the 20th
century there's a lot of writing on how
his eyes were actually blue and he
really was very close to the Germans
because he's so popular there must be a
reason so his eyes were Brown and
reality but so that's one of anyway it
was funny that is actually very
surprising so how does your work differ
from the other research that that it's
out there yeah I think part of part of
the difference is the sources that I
looked at and there's more apart from
ones that I just mentioned and went into
political archives and looked really at
you know documents of say the propaganda
ministry in the third rise of Emperor
Wilhelm and his artistic staff and
looked at what how much is the the
politicians really involved in shaping a
repertory I also looked at economic
aspects I looked at the publisher of
Verdean his archives in Italy and their
correspondence with German opera houses
and there's often surprisingly banal
reasons for the popularity of a
particular opera or composer so as well
so certain operas were already licensed
to an opera house in some place and so
another opera house would have
to pay higher fees so then they decided
oh well let's go with this early very
opera because it's just cheaper sure and
so here comes a revival of Verdi that's
that's just one example
so this political the emphasis on
political and theatre archives
administration what I kind of call the
mechanics of repertory formation is
something that hasn't been looked at
much at all and musicology okay so
that's one difference and another
difference I would say it's the very
long-term perspective that I'm taking so
I'm really the book is called from
unification to the third right but
really the first chapter starts in the
early nineteenth century with the
premises of pitying German versus
Italian music Rossini versus Beethoven
which is the foundation stone of the
anti-body
sentiment in the mid century and it ends
after the Second World War
with a brief snapshot of political
appropriations of Verdi in East and West
Germany and so this long-term
perspective has allowed me to really
trace continuities of stereotypes in
association and it's very subtle changes
in association with political changes
whereas most existing studies not a
Verdi there's not much but of reception
history in music usually focus on a very
narrow period say vogner and the third
race okay let me ask you this so Hitler
was a huge vogner fan yes did you see
any evidence that people were afraid to
then listen to Verdi yes in in some
sense so that story of Van in the Third
Reich in some sense mirrors or is a lens
a focal point of the larger story that
I'm telling which is that very had
always been popular and so after so that
was a problem in the 19th century when
German intellectuals try to foster the
idea of German dominance and German
culture and it was a problem after
Hitler took power in some opera houses
and opera directors thought oh my gosh
we have to ban any and all foreign
repertory so let's not do that
and then people complained and so then
negotiations started and they said oh
well he's dead and he's really popular
we can't quite do that and yeah so there
was a lot of negotiation which then
changed once the access pact came into
existence in 1938 then it was fine even
for the highest politicians and that
very was popular and now it could be
access propaganda and then grubbles
himself got involved and he organized a
very festival and conclusions lots of
different conclusions along with my
various premises one of them is that
there really is there are so many
continuities in this history of very
reception across the political eras that
are usually defined 1871 1914 1918
Weimar Republic third right post-war
there are a lot of continuities
including stereotypes and things about
very that have been thought about then
there are still very acute today like
what so the rise of Verdi in recent
musicology and started with the very
same questions that German writers asked
for the early 20th century which
ecologist have tried to get away from
the German bias on approaching various
music from a perspective of German forms
and that was a big agenda in the early
20th century and it was the key to
Verdi's coming back if you wish as an
acceptable academic topic in the 1990s
another example is stagings
of operas so certain scenes that were
seen as problematic in German stages for
example various big French opera Don
Carlos has a religious finale and
there's a ghost who's a monk who rescues
Don Carlos and it's all very mistake but
a happy ending and religious mystic
happy ending and that has seen to be
problematic was seen to be problematic
in the early 20th century and so theatre
directors try to fiddle with this and
cut the Opera and somehow make this
religious element more mundane okay and
that is an exact same tendency that you
see in most recent productions and so
those continuities are often that
thought to be uncomfortable because we
think we do everything new and certainly
when it comes to the third right and
continuities through that era so that
was another surprising conclusion that I
found is that and there's a strong
continuity from the Weimar Republic into
the third right with various dominance
which they just can't change even the
third right the strong political regime
can change that and very continues after
1945 as if nothing had happened for us
German composers fall out of favor
vagueness not being performed at all for
some time and then only who readily gets
back into the repertory why daddy just
stay vogner fell out of favor because he
was associated with political
appropriation and with Hitler's taste
but very in a way with very you could
have it always you could have him as the
foreigner and therefore he was bad or
you could have him as your own somehow
appropriated and which is what the Nazis
did but then he was still foreigner and
he was still good old Verdi so after
1945 he could still be performed it
didn't stick with him mm-hmm so the
continuity is certainly one one of my
conclusions but then another one is
diversity regional diversity and also
between different social strata so
German culture and especially musical
cultures often talked about as
homogenized unified entity and so I've
placed a lot of emphasis on showing the
differences between different regions
for example between in the 19th century
between Vienna Austria Catholic very
close to Italy and Berlin Russian
Protestant we're very really became a
tool and the cultural camp of this park
and in trying to associate the German
Empire with Protestantism so regional
diversity local interests another
conclusion is something that has been
talked about a lot is can information
how
be musical cannons and repertory is
being shaped and often does this talked
about as top-down there are some in
power they could be the conductors and
they could be the academics and the
intellectuals and the writers who
determine which composer will be
performed and is the composer of the day
and so in a way my book provides a
grassroots bottom-up perspective of this
by looking at a much wider spectrum of
sources of writers of daily journals of
individual agents in this process of
cannon formation so yeah that is that is
something kind of more methodological
I'm curious to know about the upper
class of Germans versus the middle to
lower class yeah was there any
difference between each social level in
musical tastes yes so it starts in the
later 19th century where Italian opera
is being associated with the aristocracy
because opera had often been had
traditionally been in our Socratic form
it's so lush it's so expensive so grand
that it was dependent on subsidies and
also it was considered to be less
intellectually demanding than pure
instrumental music and so there was the
idea fostered by the middle classes that
really Italian opera is something that
the aristocracy is favorite favorable to
and of course the aristocracy was not
supporting was not seen to be supporting
the German national cause and so the
German bourgeoisie was aligning itself
with good German music and that trope
continued in various forms later in the
20th century it was the intellectuals
that were supposedly against Italian
music and against Verdi because it was
too simple in Papa music say and that
changes in the 1920s when a lot of
intellectuals including Thomas Mann
including France vaartha writers like
that get really interested in detail in
Opera and particularly in the figure of
Verdi and show positive assets for
German culture
after the collapse of traditional German
values in the First World War including
vogner including the very idea of German
musical dominance Mary becomes a figure
that becomes interesting for
intellectuals interesting yeah well
thank you so much for being here with us
today
sharing some of your work thank you so
much for your interest in my work it's a
great pleasure to be great thank you for
more information about Professor
Kreutzer and her research please visit
our website at Yale ddu slash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale